Would you ever tell a woman to suckle a
grown man who isn't her husband?
>> Sorry. Would I ever Would I ever tell a
woman to suckle a grown man who is not
her husband?
>> Yeah, I know what you're about to bring
up just in reference. So, the short
answer would be uh no, I would not tell
her that, but I know you're about to
bring up
>> I think I don't know the exact charact
I don't know who it was, but in this
>> Who who is it? Just
>> Yeah, I I forget the name too, but I
think you're you're close to it. I think
that is it was or something like that.
>> Yeah. But anyways, right like um yeah, I
mean so in this in the case of this we
would the the suckling wasn't like it
wasn't actually done, right? It was
basically like
>> it was done
>> as far as I'm aware because I don't want
to I don't want to speak without
knowledge on a certain topic.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Let me help you. It was
done. She said that she went and suckled
him. As far as I know, so I have not
read the hadith, but as far as I know,
what I've heard at one point from uh
scholars at was
>> was that I think the the the man
consumed like the breast milk of her or
something.
>> Yeah. From her breast.
>> I I don't know if it was a direct
suckling though. I think that's that's
what Albani says at least.
>> If anybody comes and says that she did
not suckle him, they're lying because
she says that she suckled him. If they
mean that, if they come and say, "Oh,
well, yeah, breastfeeding doesn't mean
breastfeeding. It means to just uh drink
of the milk from the breast, not
directly. That's not breastfeeding
anymore, dude. They're making stuff up
to patch up the the hadith to make it to
make it better. And we have to have
enough sense to be able to recognize
when people are doing that to to make
the relig like fix the religion. Okay?
So, like with our critical thinking, we
know what breastfeeding is.
Breastfeeding doesn't all of a sudden
change because it because it makes the
religion look bad.
>> Yeah. But here's the thing, right? Is
like if you look at the commentary from
they basic and they're what what we say
is they're authoritative in interpreting
the they mentioned that it was put in a
cup for him to drink it and that was
because he was raised by her. That's
because he was raised by her and after
that it was basically to make it a like
make her like a
>> Do you agree that putting milk in a cup
is not breastfeeding?
>> It's not uh I don't know how you define
breastfeeding but it's not suckling.
You don't know how we define
breastfeeding?
>> Uh like Yeah. If you if you like suckle
on like I don't want to be
>> li Yeah. To suckle on the
>> breast like Yeah. suckling is different
than putting breast milk in a cup and
drinking, right? Like
>> Exactly. So it says that it says that
she suckled him.
>> Uh look, so I'm going to look I'll I'll
I'll answer you like this uh because I
don't want to again I don't want to be
disingenuous speak without knowledge. So
from what I know is that all of the
scholars including that like that I
know of all of the major scholars they
mentioned that this was not a direct
suckling. It was breast milk that was
put in a cup that that he drank and that
was and because of that that's the
interpretation except now I've not read
the hadith. I'll look more into the
language of it if it contradicts it but
yeah the answer is no. So I don't accept
the premise that the prophet ordered
that but I'll look into it more. So I
don't know the I'm not familiar with the
argument.
>> All right, let's look into it. So well I
got the hadith right here for you.
>> No problem.
>> Okay, it says um
Aisha reported that Salah bent sah came
to Allah's apostle and said messenger of
Allah I see on the face of Abu Hudafa
signs of disgust an entering of Salem um
into our house whereupon Allah's apostle
said suckle him. She said, "How can I
suckle him as he is a grown-up man?"
Right? This isn't pouring milk in a in a
in a bottle or a cup. Allah's messenger
smiled and said, "I already know that he
is a young man." Omar has made this
addition in his uh narration that he
participated in the battle of Bad and in
the narration of Liban Umar. Uh the
words are Allah's messenger laughed.
Now, here's a continuation of this. If
we go to the next one, it says that she
went and actually did it. Right? So,
same thing. She is Salem has attained
attained as men attain. So, he's grown
and he understands what they understand
and he enters our house freely. I
however perceive that something in the
heart of Abu Ahua whereupon Allah's
apostles said to her, "Suckle him and
you would become unlawful for him and
which Abu Hudafa feels in his heart will
disappear." So that discomfort he feels
with him walking around the house be
gone. She returned and said, "So I
suckled him and what was in the heart of
Abu Hudafa disappeared." So she did what
Muhammad told her to do, which was she
suckled that man.
>> Yeah, man. Um I think that Yeah, I have
to look into it, bro. I don't I mean I
would just say that I think that as far
as is there there could be another
narration word mentioned. I don't know.
I'm I'm not sure. But
>> yeah, there's nothing else that says
anything different from the fact that
she suckled him and to suckle him.
Nothing says that she poured milk in a
cup or something like that and then gave
it to him. Um Yeah. Just Yeah.
>> So, so I'll say this is that Yeah. I'm
going to be honest. Don't know the
answer to the argument.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, brother. There's there's not an
like an answer for you to give. Like I'm
not tell you to solve this delist.
>> No, no, no, no. I I understand your
argument, but the reason like see the
reason I'm skeptical and I'll tell you
why is because for the previous
arguments that you've made, I think that
there have been some misinterpretations
on your part that I can't answer. And
because of that, like so for example,
what I'm saying is that if I don't know
something, I'm not going to insist on
there being one interpretation. Whereas
I feel like you're doing that, at least
in a previous case. For this case, I
don't know if you're not. I would be
disingenuous to make a claim on that.
>> But yeah, I mean, for example, when you
talk about the hitting of the wife, for
example, with the previous guest or what
was the one after him, so I'm not
recalling it. The orphan girl, right? I
think there's some clearer answers
there, you know, but I could provide
those if you want. We could have a
discussion on that. But yeah, man, I'll
definitely look into the hadith of the
breastfeeding. But yeah, as far as I
know, I mean, the scholars came to that
>> basically just really quick. So
basically on face value with what the
hadith says, you would never tell a
woman to do what Muhammad told this
woman to do, right?
>> I don't know what the face value of the
hadith is cuz I don't know Arabic. But I
would say like
>> if you're talking about like directly
from the breast like taking the milk,
like if you're like I would I wouldn't I
wouldn't tell someone to do that. No.
>> Okay. So then in this case, you're
better than Muhammad.
>> No, I wouldn't say that.
>> You are you're better than Muhammad. You
wouldn't tell a woman to suckle a man to
stick her breast in in her in his mouth
if
>> Cece see that you're adding the words,
man. I don't know. Hey,
>> that's what it is. That's what it means
to suckle. We're not We're not dumb,
bro. You You're a critical thinker. I'm
a critical thinker. We know what it
means to suckle somebody. We know what
that means. We know what it means to
suckle.
>> Yeah. So, here I'm going to If the if
the scholars have basically not agreed
with the definition of suckling we're
talking about, like they came to that
conclusion somehow, you know what I
mean? Right. So who
>> their their commentary of
>> Yeah. Yeah. You would have to show me
like what it what it is that gives them
the logical conclusion that suckling.
>> Sure. I mean suckling you like do you do
you do you hear the thing man?
>> Hold on. Let's let's take it. We got to
go slow with this.
>> Gosh. No problem.
>> You guys you guys do this all the time
in this religion.
words don't mean what they say because
it's it's not favorable. We know what
suckle means. Why is it difficult and
all of a sudden it changes and well
suckle doesn't mean to suckle. It means
to pour in a cup and drink from the cup.
What that like seriously does that make
sense to you logically? I want to know
for honesty.
>> Can you let me can you let me respond
like a little bit?
>> I want to know hon if that makes sense
to you and you can elaborate if you
want. Does it does it make sense that
suckle doesn't mean to actually suckle?
>> No. What you said No. Yeah. Yeah. Can I
can I can I answer and qualify?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, yeah. What you said
makes sense? Like what I I agree like
what you said made sense. But here's the
difference, right? Is like would you
agree that there's people who
misinterpret passages in whether it be
the Quran or the Bible at face value,
but when they read the exigesis of it,
they understand the true meaning. So if
you have a consensus of scholars, the
vast majority of them basically saying
here is what X passage means and there's
no motivation for them to lie because I
don't think you actually say that the
Islamic scholars would lie about the
prophet because you disagree with
>> they do it all the time.
>> Really? So you think that the scholars
of Islam they are they they are you
wouldn't say they're unapologetic of the
prophet?
>> No.
>> But I thought you said like you don't
like Islam. You think Islam's an evil
religion, but you think the the p the
scholars of Islam and the followers of
the hadith, like the major scholars,
they're they're interpreting it through
their own lens. They're not deriving
itself.
>> Yeah. Yeah. In a lot of places, they're
making up stuff that nowhere in the
Quran or the Hadith say what they're
saying. Like it doesn't even point to
what they're saying and they just come
up with these conclusions and make stuff
up to put Islam, I guess, in a better
light or make things easier or whatever.
They do that all the time. like all of
the scholars
>> I I don't know all of the scholars but
you know a lot of them a lot of them
>> yeah man so yeah that's the thing bro is
if I I just think that there's maybe
some basis that's all I'm saying so I'm
saying yeah at face value I don't know
but I feel like if you have a consensus
of scholars who don't interpret it in
that way then I feel like there's some
more inter whether it be another hadith
that you know that's narrated a little
bit differently whether it be um whether
it be the hadith not being mass
transmitted even though it's whether
like the Arabic word use the different I
don't know. So I'm all I'm saying I'm
not making an argument or case against I
just don't know the argument. So I'm
just saying these are in the realm of
possibilities, you know. So if I don't
know something, I'm not going to insist
on the argument against it. That's
>> I got you. So to be clear, you're saying
it does make sense that suckle means to
suckle. And if a scholar is coming up
with saying that suckle doesn't mean to
suckle, but to pour in a cup or
something and drink from the cup and
then that counts as suckling, they're
going to need some some great evidence
to actually demonstrate that from the
text. And
>> yeah, of course you'll need evidence to
demonstrate that. So I'll look into that
for sure. I'll see if there's no
evidence for that, then I don't know.
>> All right. So at least for now, you're
better than Muhammad in this case.
>> All right, man. I don't know. You don't
have to come in with the attacks, but
that's okay.
>> What? Guys, no. What? CL
>> how that I just gave you a compliment
and you took it as an attack.
>> Not a it's not a compliment to a Muslim,
man. If I say you're better than Jesus,
you wouldn't accept you.
>> Well, that would just be a lie.
>> Yeah, so I'd say you're also lying.
>> Well Well, you know what? What I would
what I would have you do is make a make
a make a live stream that I can join
where you say Avery is better morally
than Jesus and we could talk about that.
>> But you know, but but saying
>> Well, I'd be glad I'd be glad to do it
on this live stream if you're done, but
I don't know.
>> Yeah, I'm definitely down. Yeah. You You
think that I'm morally better than
Jesus,
>> dude? I think you're like significantly
morally better than Jesus in the New
Testament, man.
>> Okay, awesome. Yeah, we could talk about
that one day.
>> Absolutely. So,
>> so that's a you're you're complimenting
me on my morality, not you're not
attacking me. So, in the same way, I'm
I'm complimenting you on your morality.
You're better than Muhammad.
>> All right, man. Okay. I mean, if that
that's fair. I guess I misinterpreted,
but yeah, I think you're like uh you
have much more outstanding moral
character than Jesus of the New
Testament. Okay. So, I I I see how this
I see how this is. So, um would you ever
sleep with a a 9-year-old girl?
>> Uh no.
>> Why not?
>> Yeah. Because a 9-year-old is not
physically and mentally mature.
>> So, you think it's wrong to sleep with a
9-year-old?
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Are you What? What? What sect are you?
>> Sunni or Sunni, bro. So, yeah, let me
explain the problem. So, this is this is
also time bound, right? So, for example,
if I say like sleep with a 9-year-old
girl, the reason that you know a lot of
your followers and a lot of the
Christians, they'll just say like, "Oh,
that's so disturbing, very is because
they have like a conception of the
nine-year-old girl." It's a very fair
conception of a school girl in a
backpack with, you know, going like
walking around. But this is not like
applicable to all times. So, for
example, if you look at the age of
consent in the United States in like the
mid 1800s, it was 10 years old, right?
>> What does that have to do with
>> Yeah, I'll tell you why. So that's
because when you have societies as of as
as recently as like 200 to 300 years
ago, not even 1400 years ago,
>> you had people who at around the age of
10 years old, right,
>> would essentially leave their houses,
right, and become and like live
independently per se, right? And so me
mental maturity was defined by how
literate you are. And this is not even
the standard that's just set by Islam.
>> You're not understanding of Muhammad's
actions. No, I don't. Are you Catholic,
Gabriel? I'm not sure.
>> Uh, I I don't discuss that.
>> Okay, no worries.
>> But what does that what does that have
to do?
>> Let me let me explain.
>> Hold on, please. Cuz you're not getting
to You said you're going to get to it
and you're not getting
>> I'll be I'll be more
>> Hold on. Hold on a second. Excuse me.
>> Excuse me, Cloudy.
>> So, now I got to get you back on track
cuz you're appealing to uh United States
a few hundred years ago and this, you
know, and society.
>> Sorry, I'll be more concise. Yeah, go
ahead. Is is is morality subjective?
>> No, it's objective.
>> It's objective. Okay.
>> Yes. Correct.
>> So, is sleeping with a 9-year-old girl
objectively right or wrong?
>> Yeah. So, let me let me answer that. Um,
but I can't I can't it's not a right or
wrong answer for me. That's fair. Okay.
So, and I'll tell you why.
>> It's it's either sleeping with a
9-year-old is good and
>> I'll I'll give you this
>> or morally debased.
>> Let me answer. I'll say it's okay. You
know what? I'll say in this time period
it's wrong. But let me tell you why it's
objective first. Let me qualify.
>> It's relative. Again,
>> can you let me explain why it's not
relative,
>> please?
>> All right. Perfect. So, yeah. So, the
statement like um like if I the
statement marrying a 9-year-old is
wrong, that is time bound. So, the
principle is objective. The principle is
that marrying someone who is physically
immature and prepubescent and mentally
immature is wrong. That's the moral
principle we operate on. And that moral
principle different differentiates
between the time period you're in. So in
the 1500s or in the year 600, that
principle is not the same as today. So
for example, if I say like is killing an
apostate objectively wrong? In the Old
Testament, it's fine, right? But in the
New Testament, I guess I don't know,
maybe it's okay in the New Testament,
too. I'm not too sure, right? But the
New Testament, it's wrong. So certain
moral principles can remain constant
with the conditions changing over time.
You understand? So the answer to you
would be yeah objectively it's wrong in
this time because of the because the
person is not mentally mature but in a
different time era it would not be. I
hope
>> what if what if a 9-year-old was
mentally mature?
>> No. In today's day and age, yeah, it's
impossible.
>> Well, what if?
>> No, there there's no what if. That's an
impossible.
>> It is. What what if what if a
nine-year-old was what you consider
mentally mature?
>> Yeah. So if you're talking about like in
some remote village or some like nomadic
society which could exist like remote I
guess it's very it's it is possible but
if you're talking about stand like most
societies
>> is it okay to sleep with that 9-year-old
in that in that little tribe or society
somewhere
>> dude I know you're trying to get like
the clip for your real pat
notice how you're saying that I'm trying
to get a clip when I'm asking you very
straightforward questions based on the
standards that you
>> but I'm giving you a hold Please don't
interrupt me, please.
>> Go ahead.
>> Now, all of a sudden, when I ask you
straightforward questions based on the
standards you build, you muddy the
waters when I ask you the question and
you say, "No, I know you're just trying
to get a clip right now. Don't do that.
Don't don't don't be dishonest here and
and disrespect the conversation we're
having. I'm asking you a straight up
real question." And so, that doesn't
mean that I have ulterior motives. Say
it with your chest. Is it okay to sleep
with that nine-year-old who has in some
tribe who has quote unquote mental
maturity?
>> Yes. So it does Yeah. It doesn't matter
the age. If you're mentally mature or
fit and physically mature, you're ready
for marriage.
>> So is that a yes, it's okay to sleep
with that 9-year-old.
>> So yeah, if there is a situation in any
time period of society, which doesn't
apply to our society today where a
nine-year-old is physically and mentally
relative, the answer is yes. Yeah, I
just told you.
>> So yes, it's okay.
>> Yeah. Just I just explained it. I said
he hasn't qualified yet.
>> All right. All right. Cool. Cool. All
right, bro. Oh, you can have that, man.
Enjoy Islam. Okay.
>> All right, man.
>> Enjoy Islam. You see what Muslims have
to do? This This isn't about me
debunking you. This isn't about me. You
know what I'm saying? Like I I'm I'm not
going to try to defend or or debunk or
prove you. This is not a stream where I
am proving you wrong. This is a a stream
where we are exposing the depravity of
Islam. That's it. So if you think that
there are cases where 9year-olds are
eligible to be slept with, you can have
it. Enjoy Islam. This is what Islam. Do
you guys see? You see how sick this
religion is? How sick this cult is?
Sick. This is what you become when you
join Islam, guys. When you say you're
shahada, this is what you're going to
have to defend and argue for. You're
going to have to defend PDFilia. This is
Islam. You guys see the difference with
this stream and others in this stream.
Okay, you got it. Oh, there's nothing
wrong with telling Mama to put a or tell
a woman to put her breast in another
man's mouth. Lucian, cool. All right,
welcome. Hey, enjoy Islam. There's
nothing wrong with sleeping with a
little nine-year-old, 8-year-old who's
mentally mature. Hey, you got it. Enjoy
Islam. It's okay to curse a little
orphan girl. Hey, you got it. Enjoy
Islam. This stream is about
demonstrating the depths that Muslims
are willing to go to to defend Muhammad.
That's what we're doing here. Shout out
to Muslim Lantern for inspiring this
live stream. Shout out to Muslim Lantern
for inspiring this live stream. What's a
debate? What's a debate? Muslim Lantern,
thank you, man. Thank you for launching
that video. Thank you for your slimy
tactics, your cowardice. Thank you for
being the clown that you are. Cuz today
we are glorifying God by exposing the
deeds of the devil and exposing the
fruit of the devil in Islam. Thank you,
Muslim. It wasn't flesh and blood that
told you to drop that video when you
did. I'll say that. It was not flesh and
blood that told you to drop that video,
Muslim lantern, when you did. But I
think you might have got some
inspiration.